boule care podcast
uh we've got the legendary one of the
greatest of all time
pete rock peace peace what up bro man
listen peter let me tell you something
when i was a kid
when you dropped your album i think it
was the soul brother mac and the soul
brother yeah yeah
yeah um no what was it what was the
album you dropped your solo album and it
was like 98.99
uh uh soul survivor sole survivor yeah
that was the first time like
i'm i'm 33 so at that time i was like 12
or some [ __ ]
but that was the first time
right so i i hadn't come up on your ship
without even knowing about the cl smooth
[ __ ] right so i like had to go back and
and dig in but i just want to give you
your flowers man you're a legend bro
uh welcome to the podcast thank you boss
man you know what i'm saying
you know i love hip-hop brother i love
what i do man you know
it's as simple as that man i met you for
the first time uh
i met you backstage at rock the bells
with dj i have a picture with you and dj
premiere oh okay
which is one of the most legendary
photos i've ever taken to have both of
you guys together in a photo
is a big deal um yo talk about it
let's let's get in real quick just just
you know you're dropping a new project
now it's all instrumentals right
yeah all instrumentals no samples i got
a band now
shout out to the soul brothers darrow
yannick
christopher mcbride mano neon
uh jermaine holmes marcus machado big
yuki
um the list goes on man you know i i
like i'm trying to be one of those great
70s bands like like cool in the gang and
uh
right it's it's crazy to hear you say
you're putting out an instrumental album
with no samples
yep no samples at all uh i mean listen
a producer is a producer man you know
you got to be able to make music too
like without the sampling you know what
i'm saying and these are
all my ideas with the band just playing
them over
yeah um why why go the
instrumental route as opposed to i don't
know just you're pete rock you could get
verses from whoever you want you've done
it before
so like why why why just do the full
instrumental route on the
on this go around because i want people
to to really
feel the music without no noise on it
at first you know what i'm saying funny
because that's what happened with uh
with donuts with dylan it was like
yeah i don't even want to hear anybody
rapping on donuts nope
you just want to press play on it and
just vibe and just vibe because you know
what music is a vibe it's medicine
it's heal it's a healer you know what
i'm saying so
that's my job first is to do that for
the people yeah i mean
and you know you can bring the rappers
in anytime i'm ready to do something
like that you know what i'm saying i got
a whole bunch of that coming out soon
with other rappers and with my own team
who do you have okay i
i want to get to a few errors of your
career but um
out of the new generation um
who who who's got your attention
um chris zelda facts you know what i'm
saying
um a lot of other people too um and you
know
action bronson you know all them type of
cats
freddy gibbs you know what i'm saying
like people like that i'm
that's that's that's my wave that's my
wave right there
have you tapped in with the core day kid
not yet you know i feel like you guys
would you guys would make some beautiful
music together man
your phone just just dipped out you
there
you're back
okay you're back i'm back
my phone died man i figured that's what
happened
yeah i'm on my other phone now oh good
man look p rock
um we were talking about some of the
newer artists that you were [ __ ] with
you were saying you loved griselda
uh freddie gibbs have you you and gibbs
haven't worked together yet
not yet but we talking about it we've
been talking about it you know what i'm
saying
yeah you know i might you know if if it
happens
that'd be dope you know what i'm saying
um right right now i'm more concentrated
on
um because i see cats as busy so i'm
doing
you know my own stuff with my artist
amir who's going to be
really amir okay
hey you know what album i really loved
was the record you
you and uh smoke dizzy put out together
yes
don't smoke rock don't smoke rock was
crazy
and then you put the instrumentals out
what uh would you guys do a um
a sequel to that of course
has that been talked about at all yeah
we talked about it
yeah i think i think that and the smith
and wesson show i feel like
like you know it's funny because you
you've been doing these joint projects
and i feel like this year and last year
were really kind of like the wave of
like artists fully tapping in with a
producer
you know hip boy did his thing with
benny fred did his thing with alchemist
you know conway did something with
alchemist um
who's somebody who you would like to
just zone out with and do a whole album
with that you haven't yet
closed face ghost face
that would be legendary will we
have you have you guys spoken about that
ever um
we talk like a lot we talk like a lot
all the time
and um you know we'll just have to see
man
ghost face would be insane yeah
he's my personal top five ever my
personal you know what i'm saying like
yep those things he's on my personal
list too
there's two lists right there's like
your personal list and then like the
list that you
you know the the like so when people be
like what's your top five or top ten man
i got top 20 man it's like what are we
talking about are we talking about like
everyone's list or like my favorites
because there's like a difference
my security list my most important list
has jadakiss on it and ghostface that's
fair
gotcha okay yeah ghost face them the
most consistent
uh one of the most consistent rappers
ever discography wise
album for album he could go against it's
like him and yay yep
so dope and i know like if we ever work
together it would be so
easy
is it easy to work with pete rock yeah
how [ __ ] yeah i just the most you
know what you know what you know what
it's easy to work with me when you
respect me
okay so you got to make sure that the
artists
understand see because i think that
that's an important thing to say because
if someone's going to do something with
pete rock they got to understand it's a
full collaborative process you're pete
rock you know what i'm saying
yeah you can't you can't be
disrespectful to my to my
um to the way i do
you know to do where i'm great right
because i i do feel like what like guys
like yourself guys like primo
i wish that there was more of records
like the record you did with dizza
i wish that there was more like i like i
i can't tell you how excited i was
when you did the joy with
with with holding yay and when you had
when when you were in that pocket where
yay was doing
the good friday records and you were
working with kanye yeah
um i was just so excited because i'm
like this is what i want to hear
pete rock and kanye why didn't it happen
sooner you know what i mean yeah i know
it would have but you know like i look
at it like
you could just set it down right there
thank you thank you i look at it like
you know
like he's from my school and that was
bound to happen regardless you know what
i'm saying
talk talk about that era um where you
were tapping in with yay and
and the joys those are my two favorite
kanye verses
probably ever um thank you when he said
uh the the holy trinity a bad [ __ ] in a
bag
or some hennessy in the mirrors where i
see my only enemy yo let me tell y'all
something about kanye on the lyric
tip homeboy is nice he's super nice
right right take that i will not never
take that away from him
and he's very talented you know nah for
sure man
um was there any records you did with
yay that we didn't hear
yeah i did i laid about eight beats but
i think he might have went in on more
than just one
right but i never heard it
and i doubt if he's using anything but
you know what i mean
right right right right um all right so
so you got to you
you put the band together we're getting
uh
some some great instrumentals some great
music uh
from you um the person who i haven't
let's talk about you and and and and why
why haven't we seen a verses
with pete rock
i feel like you're the obvious guy to do
one as far as the
producer i wouldn't mind seeing you an
alchemist
i mean i i put it out there already man
but nobody's biting so
it's all good how how dope was it for
you as a fan of the culture to see the
rizza primo
uh battle i liked it i liked it
you know what i'm saying but i just felt
that there was a lot of
things that needed to be rectified with
with the way
it was coming over the the instagram oh
definitely yeah there were some
that was before they were doing them in
person and it was a big production
yeah yeah in and out and you know
it was a lot of it was just a lot of
stuff that
that needs to be fixed you know what i'm
saying let me ask you this pete do you
feel like you're underappreciated as a
as
when it comes to hip-hop overall
do you feel like you get your flowers
you deserve well i feel like i
get my flowers sometimes you know what
i'm saying and you know i
i really i really don't care man right
what i'm saying because i love
music regardless of how people where
people want to place me i don't care
about that [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
what i care about is what's already up
there in the sky it's already
everything i've done man is on top tear
so i'm not mad at nobody or nothing or
cats not recognizing you know
my talent you know what i'm saying but
you know real people know what time it
is you know what i'm saying
real people know what it is i'm not
bothered by none of this [ __ ] because
i have real talent yo what i appreciate
about you is you're extremely
unfiltered on twitter yeah your twitter
be going
up yeah because
you know i'm just trying to show people
that you know there's a real side to me
and that you know even with the
disrespect
i really don't care about that you know
what i'm saying i'm i'm saying things
for me
and for people who agree with it or
disagree in a respectful way
not in a disrespectful way because you
could disagree but you don't got to be
disrespectful
i think that that's something that um
we've lost sight of right
is that you you if you know
if you don't see eye to eye with someone
i feel like in 2020
it's automatically a enemy or
really really contentious conversation
like you could be texting somebody
and somebody will take you take it
totally the wrong way because
they they can't see a facial expression
or you know
they assume that you're getting at them
you know what i'm saying
even even like even like if you have any
sort like you know
i don't [ __ ] with donald trump right i
don't yeah yeah right
i i i voted for joe biden
at the same time i have my critiques of
joe biden
just like you did i see on you i saw i
saw some things you've said
but what's crazy is you can't say those
things out loud
no without without people coming at you
like bro like
like it's it's almost like you can't
even critique people anymore
i don't care
[Laughter]
yo yo let me tell you something in the
beginning i used to be like oh my god oh
my god oh
this oh he just called me this he just
disrespected me just uh
but i see what it is man i see these low
lives man they they just
like to comment to get that that that
you know so they could go back and run
back and tell them yo i was arguing with
people
and then he gets some followers behind
that yeah it's almost like there's
people who wait around online all day to
be offended
it's like what are you doing with your
life were you just sitting on twitter
waiting and waiting to get offended
they're not doing nothing you know what
i'm saying so that's another thing
that's in thought you know like all
these cats ain't nobody they just home
rubbing on their peas right right right
right right
um yeah i saw hey give me your honest
thoughts um
i really enjoyed i saw you tweeting
about the tyson fight
i really enjoyed watching uh first of
all mike looked nice
he looks sharp let me tell you man i i
look back on
both of those careers and i look at how
they
used to just dance on people like roy is
the best boxer dancer ever
you know back in his heyday of course
even them giving this us you know um
giving us this fight now is like it's
well appreciated because
this it's great entertainment for the
times we're in man we need some type of
picker-upper you know what i mean yeah i
thought they did a great job whoever the
trailer people are they did uh you know
even the jake the jake paul [ __ ] you
know that was that was great
that was crazy that was crazy and i mean
i i love nate robinson he's a nick you
know what i'm saying
but when you when you pop in that [ __ ]
and you ain't packing that [ __ ] up man
you you really not gonna back that up
man
that's a recipe for disaster um
we have a did you pay attention to the
grammy nominations
no so the the best rap album category
this year
was extremely it was some real hip-hop
[ __ ] they got nominated
really yeah i saw something online i
know freddie gibbs got nominated freddie
gibbs got nominated uh
royce the five nine got nominated yeah
royce yep royce
j j electronica uh
nas for kings disease and uh and this
kid from l.a named d smoke
i'm wondering d smoke is um a really
dope talented kid from inglewood out
here in la he's uh
he was on that show rhythm and flow on
netflix but really [ __ ]
amazing artist i'm wondering though what
was your favorite album of the year
of this year of this year busta rhymes
oh it's so good it's so good
yo tell me how crazy the farrakhan
speech is on there
and how it leads in the bus to spasm i
said
man people are so afraid of the truth
bro you know what i'm saying
and that's one thing i commend about
busta rhymes like
you know doing this album you know what
i'm saying because it's real times right
now
and you you know to say to do something
else other than something real
you know it ain't the move you know what
i'm saying so
ele is the best album in 2020
yo it's crazy too because it tells you
how important it is to make timeless
music because a lot of this album
some of these songs are 10 years old and
the fact that they still
resonate right now
like and then so you're part of the
intro
talk about how old that record is man
1992 and um
you know it was you know the joint i did
for nasa and
right he brought it back on some necks
you got that
i thought it was dope he gave you the
feature like it's a featuring pete rock
i love i love busta rhymes we have a
really good relationship going back
since 1991 so that's my guy
yeah i mean and um you know
[ __ ] man look there was a lot of great
music that came out
you know what i'm saying but but the way
some of the music that you hear there's
no real structure on the album this
buster album has structure
it's front to back front to back and you
can tell that buster cares about his
audience
you could tell that he made this album
for them
and you could tell that he is a hip
hopper
in his heart all the way he he took the
time on this album and
in an era where no one takes time on
their projects
everybody's just rushing and throwing
stuff out and there's no rush to throw
music out
i want you to take me back to obviously
you're a part of my favorite album
evermatic
which is probably if you were to you
know
interview a hundred taste makers and hip
hop it'd probably get the most first
place votes
you know what i'm saying i think it's
probably undisputedly
that's a mount rushmore album yes um
when did you first meet nas 1990
or 91 when i was hanging around with a
large professor in uh
queens shout out to large professor now
that was this this was uh was this
around the time
live at the barbecue at release or was
it before that
it was it was around it's around that
time
and and yep before that
and when you're working on illmatic when
you're working on on
with nas are you like aware at the
moment because i feel like
so much we're living in the moment so
sometimes we don't realize like the
history we're a part of or
or like like were you like aware at the
time are you conscious of like yo this
[ __ ] is like
this is gonna change hip hop well
depending
on who got the beat and anytime i'm
working with him
you know something good is gonna happen
so that's basically what that was and
when i
when he heard the beat that it triggered
something in him and you know
he on the spot he came up with the hook
and he was like yo i want you to
i want you to say this hook i want you
to sing this hook you know
did it i ain't going to do it at first
but i did it i ended up doing it
yeah it's crazy because i also feel like
you don't get a you don't get enough you
don't get props as much as you should as
a
also as a as an artist i mean as a
producer
you know you i just feel like as an
artist as well
i feel like you don't get the uh the
respect maybe
am i supposed to be getting all this
respect and stuff from like i don't know
i don't care bro yeah okay because you
know what people are gonna be who they
are it's
all good man you know you you got people
out here who are clueless
on what pete rock has done you know how
important he is
all that you know what i'm saying and
then you got people that show love
you got people that's like yo you are
that [ __ ]
still you know what i'm saying and um
hey man you know
it is what it is you know what i'm
saying i'm not i'm not mad at nobody you
know there's so many dope people that
produces
rappers that i i want to work with still
um yeah i would love to hear the for the
freddie gibbs for me would be
would be would be special
and listen i would put my foot in that
one and the end of a
ghost face a ghost face project would be
[ __ ] insane
that that put two feet in there yo look
man quick break from the podcast and
tell you about odd socks all right
they're our official sponsor they
support what we do here at the bootleg
kit podcast
all right they got the nickelodeon
joints they got these uh
yo shout out to ghostbusters i might
keep those um anyway
what you gotta do is hit that
oddsoxofficial.com if you want to
support what i do the bootleg cab
podcast then support our partners odd
socks go buy some socks man
holidays are coming up odd
socksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev you're getting 20
off of the most comfortable socks in the
world
shout out to odd socks i feel like
you've you've definitely
probably answered who are your favorite
um
producers of all time i want to know who
do you think
is the most slept on two or three
producers ever
two or three producers you mean like two
or three producers that that you think
deserve to be in more conversations
because i do think there are a lot that
are you know i think large professors
are one of them i think there's a lot
but like
who do you got in that in that in that
list black milk
black milk is so cold black milk needs
more props you know what i'm saying he's
dope you know what i'm saying so dope
and i don't know if people up on
on vitamin d but he dope too oh my
goodness
he's a he's one of my new favorite dudes
yeah
i i yeah derringer's dope the griselda
guy he's
he's great i think like yeah danger gets
it in you know what i'm saying
but i'm i was an alchemist fan you know
what i'm saying
of course aoc man yeah
yep alchemist and um you know everyone
else i'm a fan of all producers
it's not a fan like ninth one everybody
i like everyone
you know what i'm saying is there um hey
i'm gonna say
dilla and mad lib are my two favorites
yo how crazy were both of those mad lib
projects with fred
wow stupidity come on man be having
joints man god beat i heard matt i heard
he made a lot of bandana on an ipad
which is crazy he's played me so many
joints
and sent me so much stuff we talk almost
every other day
and then you know when i tell people
that they're like i can't get them on
the phone for nothing
i can't find them right
yo um do you like
shout out to mad lib but do you think um
like how often do you because you know i
i heard this story that kanye wants
snatched drums from dr dre back in the
day he probably did
how often do you like as producers share
like sounds or like have you ever hit
somebody up like yo where'd you get
those drums
no not not pete rock
i find my own kicks and snares man i got
i'm a dig i'm a heavy digger man that's
all we do when soon as we put the needle
down we're
we don't with the you know we looking
for samples but sometimes when we put
the needle down you'll hear a
popping ass snare bop you know what i'm
saying or a hi-hat or
you know right you can
make snares from scratch homie let me
ask you this because
um in 2020 how are like like what what
do you use to make beats are you using
like like this
because obviously times have changed
technology's changed back in the day we
used to carry records when we would dj
now we don't need records how are you
still using
your old school equipment are you on
like reason pro tools like what are you
using
for vinyl forever i'm not a digital
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying you ain't
digital at all you haven't
you have a compromise on that i do the
digital work don't get it
[ __ ] up right well i do that [ __ ] but
i'm when i'm home man
it's vinyl man and even like certain 45
parties i may pop up and do
i'm bringing a little box out of vinyl
damn the 45s
that's a beautiful thing man are you do
you have anything else that you have a
in the can right now pete that you're
working on outside of this instrumental
project it's about to drop
um yes a whole bunch of stuff a whole
bunch 2021 is gonna be an awesome
you know can you kind of give us any
sort of hints
um i got my band pete rock and the soul
brothers
album we're working on right
not the peach tremendous three they're
they're they're featured on that
on every beat they playing over every
joint that you hear right then we drop
an
album right and then my man amir comes
the rapper the mc and we got a mixtape
coming out called worth its
weight and soul where i just just taken
anything
rick james outstanding and fat back man
and
in certain you know obscure beats and
mixing it all together and
you know give people a feel of who this
guy is
and um you know it's just one of those
things that you could just
it's a mixtape it's free and you can
just like kind of
jam to it and lyrically dude is dope
how what is your uh temperature on
hip-hop currently
i feel like it's been in a dark place
and i feel like things are starting to
turn around a little
it's starting to turn around so my
temperature is right now
is 65 degrees okay okay
yeah you're not freezing no i'm not
freezing but i'm in the middle somewhere
you know what i'm saying and i'm trying
to get to the heat couple years ago you
might have been freezing a couple of
years ago
i was i was in an igloo [ __ ] was rough
[ __ ] was rough i was angry and upset
you know saying uh you know cause i
can't stand whack
beats and lyrics i can't yeah it's it's
like
some some some somewhere down the line
this this like
idea of like super over modulated
just very just it's just a lot of this
[ __ ] that was coming out just sounded
like noise bro
exactly man and it was just like man i
know i was
angry in the beginning because it was
going over my head like damn these guys
ain't learning
maybe we gotta re-teach them
that's some real [ __ ] and then i snapped
out of it you know what i'm saying
and was like all right you know let me
just put some music out and see
who bites that's fair hey uh when you
worked with uh
with yay on the joy were you were you in
was that when you did you go to hawaii
for that
yes i did what was that what was that
what was that trip like what was it like
being out there working on history
because obviously that ended up on watch
the throne
but um you know that was my beautiful
dark twist of fantasy
you know sessions yep yep yep and um
it was great i mean [ __ ] that dude is
living like a
prince you know um at least on the
hawaii side i've been to his malibu
did that was that his mouth no no no
that was russell um
the comedian i went to hang out russell
peters
yes in malibu and he told me who lives
around him and near him and i think
jay-z lived down the street and
kanye lived over there and so so forth
but anyway we was in hawaii
and had a huge
you know it was it was great that i
hadn't had fun
yeah it was crazy because at that time
he brought rizza into the fold
he brought you into the fold and it was
like
finally like these this is the people we
want to see kanye work with these are
the people who inspired him like
i laid eight beats i made eight eight of
my own beats
you know what i'm saying and and we
narrowed it down to one
right you know what i'm saying that's
crazy
yes but i mean you know i had so much
fun i meant
that was my first time meeting rick rose
rick bro i mean rose you know what i'm
saying um
i met kit cutty
that day yeah i met john legend
and his wife that day wow
yeah and then while we were working all
day and then kanye had these
little pieces of paper up all over the
studio saying no twitter
no twitter that tells you how long ago
it was because now would be no instagram
yeah i remember he did something like
that online where he talked about you
know
and then when i went over there and was
in the studio you know
he had it all over the studio were you
hey
you were you there to witness rick ross
laying down his verse for devil in a new
dress
no i didn't i didn't see that go down
because that's one of my favorite verses
but look
uh the project comes out next friday or
tomorrow
or tonight number 11 december 11. so
next friday
yes um the volume three
and then and then 2021
so much more coming what
can't wait to start and there it is
hey hey hey and uh shout out your artist
amir like how can we find him online and
all that just we can tap in with him
he goes by am
on instagram with you know periods
between each syllable
all right my g well look i appreciate
your time and and
and thank you for charging your phone
[Laughter]
yeah and up also you know go on my page
if you want to hear like two clips of
of the mixtape you'll see you'll see the
cover
with me and him on there yeah are you
gonna be doing a vinyl pressing at all
yes yep yep boom ghost support man
have fun with it you know what i'm
saying you got to pete rock thank you
for your time bro
god bless you kids yes sir all right